why does route 66 matter
hi my name is jean and i'm from france
and last year i went on a trip in the
west coast
and we passed by route 66
our trip was from l.a to chicago
although we were taking the mother road
we would stop at all the museums along
the way we stopped at the
the one in elk city oklahoma and we
stood on top of the train
i'm fabian from german last year i was
visiting my family in california
by driving on route 66 i had to stop to
take photos of the beautiful sunset
the plan of the trip is they have no
plan at all
[Music]
my husband and i went back and even
visited route 66 and williams for our
honeymoon
[Music]
hey
[Music]
wise route 66 is not only famous but
internationally famous
the road starts in chicago slides down
the country
and ends up all the way in santa monica
convert that distance to time and you
get a different story
in 1926 the road was commissioned by
1957
the interstate highway system began and
it bypassed the route by 1970
in 1985 route 66 was fully
decommissioned
route 66 has been in the shadows twice
as long
as it was in the spotlight but there's
still this energy around it i spoke to
ron warnick he's the editor
of route 66 news which is an obsessive
route 66 site
and his articles just came alive with
people reminiscing
about route 66
it was about oklahoma joe's it was this
dive bar
in albuquerque near the university of
new mexico campus
i put it out there and pretty soon all
sorts of people were exchanging their
memories
about the bar
the road has three distinct eras it's
got secrets
and surprises and even a future
[Music]
the big texan steak ranch in amarillo
has a challenge
eat 72 ounces of steak and sides
in under an hour and you get it for free
i am going to switch to phone mode here
all right before you get to a cardiac
arrest threatening challenge like this
you actually have to go back more than
100 years
before federal highways networks of
largely privately owned auto trails
like the ones on this 1920 rand mcnally
map
were standard look at the chaotic number
of options
in the legend as federal highway funding
laws were passed in the 1910s and 1920s
new maps planned a linked highway system
like this one drafted by world war one
general john pershing this telegram from
april 30th 1926 from springfield
missouri
established route 66 they initially
wanted the nice round number of route 60
but
settled for 66. cyrus avery is called
the
father of route 66 for helping create
the highway to promote his home of tulsa
and creating the us highway 66
association the next year that
connection from chicago to santa monica
was
always a weird shape and less intuitive
than transcontinental road but it had
lobbying interest
behind it and a good starting point with
existing roads
texaco raided road conditions in maps
like this 1934 one as the legend shows
route 66 was just a graded road in parts
basically flattened earth look at the
journey from amarillo to glenrio
there are still parts of route 66 that
look like this today but they finished
paving the whole thing
in 1937. to get all that work started in
the 1920s
the route 66 association pushed stunts
and did publicity
that wouldn't have seemed out of place
in the 1950s and 60s when a
transcontinental foot race called the
bunion derby was run
the association made sure a big part of
it
took place on route 66 but it was
struggled that initially made
route 66's reputation we're going to
california ain't we
all right then let's go to california
the great depression
and dust ball a rut of drought and
erosion
sent families looking west for a better
life route 66 was perfectly designed to
scoop them up
leading john steinbeck to write that
these migrants come into 66 from the
tributary side roads
from the wagon tracks and the rutted
country roads
66 is the mother road the road of flight
the records show that highways 60 and 70
actually admitted more traffic to
california route 66 had become
the iconic mother road and then things
really got going
i have a slight weight before i dine
alone so there's time for activities
this thing's terrifying
this boot's a metaphor for steak
and boots
[Music]
i feel like the only way to go mega vi
is to get that 72 ounce steak
okay see that big 66 on there amarillo
texas
is a good example of a big route 66 town
they were already a transportation
center this 1926 map
the year route 66 started shows amarillo
was a railroad hub
after world war ii ended that existing
commerce and route 66
made it easy to add roadside attractions
and it's still that way today
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
over time route 66 did this for towns a
lot smaller than amarillo too
this is the middle of the video by the
way right
now it also did it for vega texas
carolyn was nice enough to be my tour
guide she showed me her house
[Music]
ben's dad and grandfather and me
oh wow
[Music]
she's very into dinosaurs armor wrench
and
spikes and teeth
and so where did you find these out
north of town
and she also showed me the magnolia gas
station which got started just before
route 66 became official
she actually helped restore the space
including the second floor
where people used to live
[Music]
yep okay it's a filling station
but somebody said at one time they also
sold office i'm not too sure about that
part
the kitchen was green the bedroom was
[Music]
blue
[Music]
those pictures are neat because they
show the horses pulling the
cars out of the water
to support all that travel and all those
attractions
route 66 had a unique motel culture
of course even as it succeeded route 66
was
limited by the prevailing prejudices of
the time the green book was a traveling
guide for black motorists
to find safe logic in tucumcari new
mexico in 1960
listed options were scarce route 66 made
a culture but
it didn't change the existing one and in
the 1960s
just as the route 66 road trip hit its
peak
the road itself was already being
[Music]
eclipsed
[Music]
[Music]
so
today glen rio new mexico is a ghost
town
it's not alone
[Music]
after the interstate highway act of 1956
new better funded interstates were built
for defense
and infrastructure in texas and new
mexico you can see how i-40 followed
route 66 in some spots
but also split away this is what that
can look like
but it doesn't have to
we had the privilege of designing and
creating two murals one here in joplin
missouri and another in galena kansas
we wanted to help revitalize and show
off our local area on historic route 66
route 66 i'm the president of the
oklahoma statewide route 66 association
and i'm the chair of the tulsa route 66
commission
about 10 years ago i sold everything i
owned and left the country and i
backpacked for 10 months throughout
southeast asia and europe
when i got home to tulsa which is where
i was raised
i thought okay i've seen all these
amazing places what does tulsa have
of course route 66 goes right through
tulsa i thought well it's been here the
whole time i haven't really paid
attention and started exploring it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm larry smith and i'm owner operator
of the motel safari in tucumcari new
mexico
on historic route 66.
yeah this is the motel i'm staying at
i had a wall in my job at the time and i
noticed while i was driving 66
that the road was losing a lot of that
older generation
it really needed the right people to own
the businesses
along the route but saving route 66
doesn't answer the big question
why it matters so i did not eat a 72
ounce steak
but i found somebody who did
this is the most excited i've been for
an interview since i talked to an
astronaut
[Music]
the story behind it is that um i compete
in track and field professionally i
throw the shot
i kind of injured at the time and i
performed really terribly
and we were going to drive through
amarillo i heard about the
the stakes so i'm like i have to have
one win and
honestly it's not the fullness it's the
uh
it's the chewing by the end i was like i
can't do anything else
and i was drinking as much water as
possible to get it down
i am glad i did it but i don't know if i
would ever do that again
i mean and i do a lot of ridiculous
things and
hey didn't do well at this track meet so
i'm going to make a 72
mistake to prove to myself that i can
overcome something
the big texan ranch isn't on route 66
anymore
the owner moved it closer to i-40 in
1970
and yet it still is route 66.
we think of places on a map as dots but
maybe a place can be aligned
[Music]
there was dessert as far as they can see
i was getting to the point where i
needed a break from two
patients in and out so i called up
my friend from med school like hey you
know what we have this window
would you be interested in the road trip
route 66 kind of became a character in
our journey
it was kind of like the oregon trail
with all the challenges popping up
and the prize at the end was our new
home at the end of the highway
i had a flash tire so i took my camera
out and took some long exposure shots
of my car and the nightstand so the
graduation gift to my three boys
as they exit high school is a 14-day
driving road trip
out west st george utah to meet
my biological family my
great great grandfather ramon negrete
emigrated from mexico to a tiny town
in arizona called williams in the early
1900s
before route 66 was there he painted the
house yellow
and it is still there today the yellow
house in williams
we think my great grandma still haunts
the house
what i love about route 66 is that it's
not just a road
that's going through tiny towns
and big towns in america it's
a road that goes through people's
histories
and carries legacies of perseverance and
hope
and i think that's what makes it so
fascinating and so beautiful
[Music]
all right that's it for this road trip
along route 66 i'm about to read a
couple of comments from the last episode
all about why every suburb looks the
same
but first i just want to give a little
plug for the vox video lab
in there right now i've got a special
video that shows
exactly how i did one shot in
the route 66 video that you just saw
it's an
obsessive nerdy technical breakdown and
that's the kind of behind
behind-the-scenes stuff that
you always get in the video lab in
addition to
supporting big videos like this one now
let's look at a couple of comments
as a european it's so weird to see
streets without a pavement sidewalk
where censored are you supposed to walk
well
yeah city beautiful and vox both made a
video on this
in the same day yes this is the craziest
coincidence i've experienced
in almost 100 videos um we turned out to
be video soul mates
and we made this video very very close
apart even though both of us had been
working on it for months
but the take home point here beside a
crazy coincidence or glitch in the
matrix
city beautiful is an awesome channel if
you're interested
in urban planning go ahead and add them
to your subscription feed
if you want more videos like that that's
it for this one the next episode of this
road trip edition of almanac
is the last one and it tackles how roads
can shape public policy
in really unexpected ways